this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
this week he's taking a look at the
period weaponry in rising storm 2
vietnam just just as we see depicted you
open it up with the lever
close it up and then when you pull the
trigger you get that iconic bloop sound
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
up the royal army's museum and continue
to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
strangely enough the first thing i
noticed about the ak here
was the ejection pattern if you've seen
a real ak fired
it's got a really aggressive forward and
upward
ejection pattern so slight slightly
weaker and off to the side ping
something in my brain it wasn't
quite right there that's something
you're only going to get absolutely
right
if you've had a camera behind a real ak
shooting or
have found some footage of it doing that
the other the other thing from this
first person perspective
is the depiction of recoil which i think
is good
the the ak is an excellent weapon but
the impulse of
a relatively powerful intermediate
cartridge
and the shape of the buttstock and the
mass of the bolt carrier
slamming back means it does tend to
jump so although the ak was designed
very much for automatic fire
it was two to three rounds from the
shoulder anything more than that and it
does
does become a bit uncontrollable and i
think that comes across well
um i've grabbed an ak not because none
of you've seen an ak before you have
this is one of my favorite objects in
the collection i've chosen this russian
type 2 as we as we tend to call them
because of
this on the butt g p dylan
1 7 and long story short
this belonged to colonel gregory p
dillon of the 107 air cavalry
this is actually from vietnam and it's
it's really something to hold this every
time i pick it up
just a quick word on some of the
gameplay mechanics that are
that i find interesting i appreciate any
depiction
of suppression so if you've ever played
paintball or airsoft you know you know a
little bit of what it's like to have
something that might hurt you or at
least annoy you
fly right past you and it forces you to
keep your head down and an awful lot of
firepower
is about keeping the enemies heads down
while some of you maneuver into position
to
attack them and so many games just don't
do it
it's a really quite an engaging bit of
gameplay if you can get it right now i
haven't played this one
but it looks like they might have
something i didn't notice right away is
the little icon that pops up
where you've got your weapon resting on
something and i think that
implementation
of a stability mechanic might be the
only one i've seen
i've played games where you press a
button to sort of hook on to something
and lmg is where the bipod sort of
deploys automatically if you're in the
right sort of context i haven't seen
that for
rifles and it's completely well not
completely realistic
but it's based on of course the real
world where if you can
at all possibly steady your weapon on
something you will the weapon is visibly
more stable
less muzzle flip and player is able to
return fire and take out the enemy so
really impressive
not a super common machine gun in
video games though it does exist
elsewhere it fits the the vietnam
setting
as slightly long in the tooth but not
but still
current ish um it looks to be well
represented i haven't got one handy to
show you but we do have them in the
collection here i am really intrigued by
something else i've not seen done before
is the idea that you have to put the gun
on something to reload it
this uh this idea of ramboing it from
the hip that happened
reloading it whilst carrying it at the
hip
yeah it's probably doable but you
wouldn't you put it you'd rest it on the
deck apart from anything else you want
to make yourself a smaller target while
you reload
and these are big heavy cumbersome thing
so to have an actual mechanic where one
of the downsides of having a machine gun
is you've got a restaurant something to
reload it
thumbs up there for that for that one
we've also got overheating
represented which we've seen before but
normally overheating is a sort of
arbitrary set period of time after which
the gun just
stops which isn't really how it works
how it works is more like what we see
here
where the more you fire something
in a sustained way the more adverse
effects you experience
before it eventually fails and when it
fails it's down
it's gone it's not as simple as waiting
for a bar to decrease as we as we
normally see or maybe
hammering a button to get it to somehow
cool down quicker so the the idea
that it's got sufficiently hot to glow
red
and then your point of impact deviates
that's somewhat realistic so as the
barrel
droops very slightly and it wouldn't be
noticeable
necessarily unless you really went to
town your bullets are no longer hitting
where they used to be hitting
the m79 is of course a staple of any
vietnam setting and of course pretty
iconic from things like
terminator 2 on the fictional side of it
as well
i can't resist grabbing one to show you
so this is a really
elegant solution to a problem uh prior
to this
you have rifle grenades and they're real
pain they've got tremendous recoil
they're quite hard to aim and they're
almost a throwback to the first world
war
where we're launching grenades off the
end of bolt-action rifles the technology
is not
too far away from that what the shoulder
fire grenade launcher allowed you to do
was be a lot more precise at a given
distance
although we don't usually see them used
with the sites in
fiction the sites were pretty critical
and we that exact mechanic is replicated
in the game
and quite excitingly the adjustable
nature of the site is as well
so you can adjust this in 100 yard
increments
up to well not quite up to 375 yards
when you are of course at quite a steep
angle just just as we see depicted you
open it up with the lever
close it up and then when you pull the
trigger you get that iconic bloop
sound which i think is really quite well
represented
take cover
[Music]
well that's a weapon that really makes
one consider one's life choices
isn't it i know i've said in a previous
video that uh flamethrowers aren't
particularly
tactically effective and we're more of a
psychological thing
needless to say i did not mean for the
poor person who gets coated in
burning fuel it's more sort of on the
open battlefield that they their
effectiveness falls away and actually
could be a bit of a liability for you if
you're carrying this thing
not because a shot to the tank would
explode it
probably wouldn't if you've seen the old
mythbusters episode about
gas tanks in cars it's actually pretty
hard to ignite
fuel tanks so that aspect of the
flamethrower is
as a liability is overrated but equally
it's big it's heavy it's clunky you have
to basically stand up and go toe-to-toe
with a bunker a lot of bravery required
and pretty traumatizing for everyone
involved now it's
true of all fighting of course but uh
yeah there's a reason why
flamethrowers are effectively banned
although they're not actually banned and
they are still
on issue to certain armed forces around
the world
what a great representation of an m16a1
it's always it's one of those sort of
go-to weapons that i
immediately latch on to when i when i
see or pick up a new game
how have they done the weapon m16 ak mb5
slightly ak it's one of those perennial
iconic firearms and this is a really
good
rendition as i say in terms of the
detail they it's got all the right
features for an m16a1 something i didn't
see
is any hint of unreliability that might
reflect some of the
realities that the soldiers had in the
early years in vietnam with this weapon
otherwise very good we see the bayonet
fitted at one point these days we're not
used to thinking of
ar-15 patent uh weapons m4's m16
as having bayonets they are still issued
in the us forces but the us army no
longer trains with the bayonet as i
understand it
we the bayoneting i've seen in in the
gameplay footage
seems a little bit off uh it seems like
you sort of pokey pokey and they fall
over
and obviously real bayonet combat is a
bit worse than that
the idea that you just sort of poke them
when they fall over is perhaps a bit of
a lapse in the
otherwise very robust realism of this
game the uh the sights the way the iron
sights are done i think this is probably
true of all the weapons in the game but
i noticed it in particular with the m16
iron sights there's a lot of relative
movement of the front and rear sight as
the character moves through the space
which tells me that the weapon model and
therefore
the hit detection effectively is
respecting reality
so although you're not lining the weapon
up like as if you're in vr or something
or
had a real one it's not just cosmetic
animation of a weapon
and the bullets go wherever they go it
is respecting where the muzzle is
pointing which is really important for a
realistic
shooter
a good implementation of an m60 i think
a good lmg slash gpmg depiction so we've
got all the same features as the the dp
in terms of
you've got to rest it on something to
fire it in any way accurately
good you've got to rest it on something
to open the top cover
put a new belt on close the top cover
[ __ ] it or that great
the model looks good it's another iconic
vietnam war
weapon it's always disappointing in a
shooter where
lmgs and gpmgs and things look and sound
the part but they feel weak
they're doing if anything less damage
than the equivalent rifle round which
makes no sense of course the machine gun
is
a rifle plus in the right situation
properly rested supported and trained
and all that
so this looks like it really does nail
that kind of force multiplier if you
like of
a fully automatic ball power cartridge
firing weapon
the the mat 49 the french submachine gun
originally french anyway
this is this is fascinating i had to
look this up but this is the only this
is
only this has only appeared in vietnam
games and i think it's because
people have only really encountered this
in the context of vietnam in the hands
of
bc or nva soldiers what it actually is
is a
as the name would imply late 40s french
design
for a nice compact submachine gun with a
folding
magazine housing foregrip it's quite an
interesting weapon
very square and blocky as we see in the
in-game model there
but it's it's nice that there's a nod to
the fact that this is this is a
legacy of the french involvement in
vietnam people tend to forget that it
all kicked off
at a time when france was involved very
heavily and of course other nations were
involved such as
australia and that's represented in the
game as well
right uh oh the rpg seven we've talked
about it before
it crops up all over the place what can
we say that hasn't been said before
uh 80 millimeter recoilless gun
effectively
with rocket assisted uh munitions we
tend to call it a rocket-propelled
grenade launcher
it's uh it's well done here the loading
the firing all looks good the model
looks great too
the thing i want to talk about is the
back blast so we saw the warning on the
screen there
be be mindful of your uh back blast of
your recoilless weapon because this is
the thing i mean
rocket launchers are no no picnic to be
standing behind either because you've
got
a rocket exhaust in the face and a
certain amount of blast but because the
rpg
is an open-ended gun there's a lot of
high pressure
backwards several meters behind and so
firing it indoors is a problem
probably need to redecorate after that
and if there's anyone in sort of
rear 180 they are not you're not going
to be their favorite person
and as we saw there if they're too close
to the back blast
they're probably actually going to die i
saw the anti-air use there
in reality very hard to shoot down any
sort of aircraft with an rpg
not guided of course has been done
successfully done in somalia
with trenches you dig a trench to
accommodate the back of the weapon in
the back blast and you lie on your back
and you wait for a helicopter to fly
over
and you fire up into the belly of the
helicopter that works
and those of you who've tried it in
first person shooters obviously you're
not digging a trench
but aiming straight up as the thing
flies over you
is intuitively the easiest way to do it
not that it's at all easy
if you'd like to support the work that
we do here at the royal armouries both
with gamespot
um and over on our own channel have a
look at the video description we have a
couple of links
for you in there otherwise i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you